[Musik]
ich wusste wenig bei ihnen denn meine
eltern vor allem mein vater sprachen
höchst ungern über die ereignisse vor
während und nach der revolution
ich erfuhr kaum etwas über ihr leben in
russland
eines tages ich war vielleicht 16 stieß
ich auf das tagebuch meines urgroßvaters
mitgehen
ich fing an zu lesen und stellte mit
erstaunen fest dass er zu beginn der
russischen revolution die sozialen
umwälzungen befürwortete und sich davon
positive veränderungen in der russischen
gesellschaft er sprach es doch sehr bald
merkte er dass nichts seinen erwartungen
entsprach
[Musik]
er entschloss sich für die flucht denn
das leben der ganzen familie war
ernsthaft gefährdet dieser pass wurde
uns von der schweizer delegation bei
unserer abreise ausgestellt ende
september 1918
da sieht man sie alle drei sie sind
zusammen abgereist am 17 oktober glaube
ich im oktober 1918 ging in sankt
petersburg alles drunter und drüber
nichts funktionierte mehr und sie
erwischten noch den zweitletzten zu
einige möbel stellten andere überdeckten
ziemlich großen tüchern dann
verschlossen sie die wohnung und
übergaben die schlüssel den nachbarn in
der annahme dass sie nach drei wochen
wieder zurückkämen
und am schluss schreibt sie noch da
sitzen wir nun auf unseren koffern die
letzten schweizer von sankt petersburg
um 9 uhr morgens mussten wir unseren
bahnhof einfinden und nun warten wir
seit stunden inmitten von gehstöcken
regenschirme toiletten taschen und
proviant kamen neben uns berge von
gepäck leise sprechen wir über unsere
baldige rückkehr in die liebgewonnene
wahlheimat in der überzeugung dass der
spuk bald vorbei sein wird
[Musik]
doch sie kehrten nicht mehr zurück all
die schweizer die während jahrzehnten in
sankt petersburg moskau und anderen
städten gelebt haben wo ihnen russland
im zuge des wachstums einmalige
entwicklungschancen gewehrt hatte vor
der revolution lebten in russland rund
10.000 schweizer gut 8000 flohen
zwischen frühjahr und herbst 1918 nach
der machtübernahme durch die
bolschewiken aus den tagebüchern und
briefen die sie hinterlassen haben
spricht ihr schmerz über diesen abschied
für die einen bedeutet die revolution
das ende der welt wie es hermann
kaufmann empfand für andere war sie
willkommen und öffnete neue wege
so sah es anfänglich auch michaela die
ausfallquote
[Musik]
vor einem jahr begann ich dieses
tagebuch zu schreiben
bescheidene aufzeichnungen über die
ereignisse in einem land das während 23
jahren unsere zweite heimat war
ungeheuerliche ereignisse den nicht
beigewohnt haben kinder großvater wartet
auf uns in einer isolierten lage ist es
mir natürlich nicht möglich eine
vollständige abhandlung über die
russische revolution zu schreiben
aber die hier beschriebenen vorkommnisse
können vielleicht erklären warum die
anfänglich großen ideale der revolution
schließlich von fanatikern und radikalen
verraten worden
[Musik]
die extremisten bemächtigten sich der
massen die sich gerade erst von ihrer
antiken sklaverei befreit hatten
sie haben die ehrwürdigen worte freiheit
gleichheit und brüderlichkeit
missbraucht
[Musik]
sie haben den sozialismus und den
international resource
in der ganzen welt entehrt
[Musik]
geht da rein und wartet einen augenblick
der zoo hält ihr nicht lange wir bleiben
nur kurze zeit
mein wunsch nach russland genauer in den
kaukasus zu reisen entstand aus neugier
ich wollte die orte kennenlernen wo
meine familie
während gut 20 jahren gelebt hier in
zweieinhalb stunden haben wir gerade mal
diese kurze strecke zurückgelegt beim
lesen des tagebuchs kam die idee und
auch die hoffnung auf noch irgendetwas
zu finden das aufschluss geben könnte
über das was meiner familie widerfahren
ist und mit der zeit dachte ich auch
wenn ich jetzt nicht gehe gehe ich nie
mehr
[Musik]
ökonomen 1895 reisten vier tessiner und
vier italiener aus como in den kaukasus
nachdem sie ihren ganzen besitz in der
heimat verkauft hatten sie pachteten bei
einem russischen prinzen 1500 hektar an
land und gründeten am fuße des kamel
bergs die landwirtschafts kolonie san
nicola sie legten 1 berge und
obstplantagen an führten neue techniken
der viehzucht ein und bauten einen
blühenden landwirtschaftsbetrieb auf der
über 200 bauern und tagelöhnern aus den
umliegenden dörfern arbeit gab
an der spitze der kolonie standen der
agronomie karachi und seine frau
angelika kauffmann aus nutzern mit der
oktoberrevolution von 1917 und dem
darauf folgenden bürgerkrieg geriet das
land in der landwirtschafts kolonie aus
den fugen
der betrieb wurde geplündert und
zerstört die besitzer zu überstürzten
heimkehr in die schweiz gezwungen die
kelle gelang es seine familie in morcote
in sicherheit zu bringen wo er wenige
tage nach der ankunft unerwartet
verstarb
[Musik]
angelica mein engel
ihre stimme und ihre anwesenheit sind
wie ein licht in dunkle bier leiser
oscar großvater ist am schreiben wir
sollten ihn nicht stören ja mama
[Musik]
ich möchte nicht dass sich jemand sieht
kamel berg zwanzigster september 1918
wenn ich daran denke wie die fanatiker
russland in den abgrund stürzen verspüre
ich einen schmerz der sich kaum in worte
fassen lässt
[Musik]
die gedanken schweifen zu den anfängen
dieser revolution zurück die aus
russland ein neues freies und
demokratisches land machen wollte im sog
der begeisterung jener tage erschien uns
die revolution wie ein natürlicher
unvermeidbarer knall eine reife frucht
deren moment gekommen war vom baum zu
fallen
es ist unverzeihlich dass das volk
solange fast kraft und in unwissenheit
gehalten worden ist
[Musik]
nach ihrer rückwanderung lässt sich die
familie kaufmann im waadtland nieder
die damals zwölfjährige germaine
kaufmann wird sich zeitlebens an ihre
kindheit in sankt petersburg erinnern
und teilt diese erinnerungen in ihren
letzten lebensjahren immer wieder gern
mit ihren drei enkelinnen sankt
petersburg gehörte damals zu den großen
europäischen hauptstädten
ich kann mir vorstellen was es bedeutete
das kleine neuchâtel hinter sich zu
lassen und in dieser strahlende stadt zu
ziehen
zu jeder zeit stellten die großen städte
ihren reichtum ihre kultur und ihre
lebensfreude gerne zuschauer bestimmt
wann sie überwältigt von all dem glanz
und licht
man darf nicht vergessen dass die
schweiz damals ein armes land war
viele wanderten aus um im ausland arbeit
zu finden mein urgroßvater stammt aus
dem kanton neuchâtel genauso wie meine
urgroßmutter doch kennengelernt haben
sie sich im schweizer haus in sankt
petersburg dort ist ihre liebe geboren
und dort haben sie geheiratet
beide stammten aus einfachen
verhältnissen
[Musik]
unsere großmutter erinnerte sich sehr
gut an ihre kindheit in russland wo sie
bis zur revolution gelebt hat ich glaube
mit der zeit hat sie diese erinnerungen
etwas verklärt aber aus ihrer sicht
hatte sie alles so erlebt wie sie es
erzählt sie erzählte alles so intensiv
dass ich als kind glaubte wie sein eine
russische familie
ich hatte nicht begriffen dass ihre
eltern aus russland zurückgekehrt waren
denn sie sprach als wäre alles noch so
wie früher wir schliefen im gleichen
zimmer wohnung morgens um sichern und
durfte ich in ihr bett schlüpfen und sie
erzählte mir von russland sie besaß auch
einen karton voller fotografieren als
ich älter war sagte ich zu ihr
oma wenn du diese fotos nicht ein klebst
und deine erinnerungen nicht auf
schreibst wird alles vergessen gehen
wenn du nicht mehr da bist so setzte sie
sich eines tages hin und begann die
fotos in ein album zu kleben und zu
schreiben
[Musik]
dritter oktober 1918 seit monaten leben
wir in dem von den sowjets besetzten
gebiet die von mir gegründete schweizer
kolonie existiert nicht mehr
die macht ist in den händen der sowjets
und der komitees von den täglich neue
entstehen und sich wieder auflösen
vor allem aber hersteller plünderungen
und raubzüge der roten garde und andere
banden
unser land wurde beschlagnahmt und dann
die bauern und taglöhner verteilt jetzt
sind alle landbesitzer aber kaum einer
arbeitet die produktion ist eingebrochen
viele maschinen stehen still und das
land stürzt in den ruin
dabei hatte die revolution freiheit
gebracht
es weht ein neuer wind der eine
strahlende zukunft versprach doch dann
heizten die demagogen die massen an und
schnürten den klassen hass
[Musik]
was wird wohl aus diesem land was wird
aus uns
[Musik]
die mädchen möchten in gute nacht sagen
gute nacht busfahrt gute nacht meine
liebe angélica guten absatz
der winter steht vor der tür
das macht mir angst ich sorge mich um
sie alles steht still und wir sind
völlig isoliert
es ist schrecklich dass wir diesen
ausbrechenden vulkan nicht verlassen
können
canori nathan mit gene ich kann mich
kurz besuch hier wie geht's gut danke
euch dass du etwas gegessen
ja salat und
meine tante erzählte es genügte ein paar
kartoffelschalen in die erde zu stecken
und schon wuchs daraus eine kartoffel
sie produzierten auch wein und einige
tessiner und norditaliener waren
weinexperten den verkauften sie unter
anderem an der weltausstellung in
mailand 1906
rosaria gebarung ich denke meine
urgroßeltern haben es in russland zu
etwas gebracht
dann bestimmt sozial besser gestellt als
wenn sie in der schweiz geblieben wären
bis diese der restaurants fries unser
urgroßvater leitete das restaurant
discounter der ob er hatte das gesamte
service personal und die küchenbrigade
unter sich die urgroßmutter war nach
russland gereist um dort in einer
reichen familie zu arbeiten
sie musste sich um die kinder kümmern
und ihnen französisch beibringen
auch sie hatte also eine ansehnliche
stelle man sieht sie auf diesem foto
neben der hausherrin als die familie
brot an die leibeigenen verteilt sie
trägt keinen hut aber auch sie verteilt
brot an die armen
es liegt sicher auch an der sozialen
stellung ihrer eltern dass meine
großmutter dieses leben in russland wie
ein el dorado in erinnerung hat ein
verlorenes paradies
[Musik]
zehnter oktober 1918
nichts kann uns mehr erschüttern nicht
einmal solch absurde nachrichten wie die
die mir mein sohn heute überbracht hat
da man sich nicht einigen konnte wie der
stall den ich vor wenigen jahren erbaut
habe unter den zahlreichen anwärtern
aufgeteilt werden soll wird er jetzt
abgerissen
so bekommt jeder ein paar steine und
holzbrettern dass die möglichkeit so
wurde es gestern an der
generalversammlung beschlossen zu viele
wollten den steigen
gut macht ihr das gratuliere wirklich
sehr gut
wenn sie so weitermachen werden sie das
ganze land in den ruin stürzen
stell dir vor die haben sogar
applaudiert als der abbruch des stahls
beschlossen wurde
was für ein unsinn was für ein unsinn
die früheren herrscher haben vieles
falsch gemacht die industriellen die
grossgrundbesitzer aber so wo führt das
alles nur hin
nein
die mir den koffer miguel danke geht's
freut mich freut mich ich bin relativ
aus der schweiz
hallo elena schön sie kennenzulernen
ganz meinerseits ich bin ehrgeizig in
kategorie das ist unser chauffeur kann
ich ihnen helfen
der ist nicht schwer sie hat ein
schlechtes wetter in den letzten tagen
nein eigentlich nicht
sprechen sie französisch und frau pia
spricht russisch und ob er wäre die
revolution nicht gewesen
viele leute haben alles verloren wo er
viele haben ihr leben verloren
minute
[Musik]
die funktion
ein großartiger empfang
[Musik]
zumal die kinder schon mal dort vorne
das haben wir vom zug aus gesehen wohin
da war einmalig schön wunderbar der
unbekannte hat schau dir das an das ist
unter dem kommunistischen regime gab es
in der sowjetunion insgesamt 7000 leben
in denkmälern
während der historiker sind jedoch viele
zerstört worden
6000 denkmäler sind bis heute geblieben
von hier aus sieht er die ganze stadt
wenn die menschen diese treppe hoch
kommen schreitet sie sozusagen ihrem
leader entgegen
herrlich diese aussicht wohl der kamel
bergstedt rechts oder links von uns
[Applaus]
vorhin von der geschichte der revolution
die rede ist kommt mir immer in den sinn
dass unsere großmutter lehnen ihn
kennengelernt hat später sagte sie
hätte ich gewusst wir linien wirklich
war hätte ich ihn umgebracht
sie sehen aus wie kostüme ja die
kleidung ist immer wieder anders
hier steht beginn der revolution an
diesen fotos kann man die namen der
katastrophe beinahe erkennen
das war kurz vor der flucht sehen sie
irgendwie besorgt aus
[Musik]
plötzlich geht alles sehr schnell
bis dahin war alles wie im paradies eine
heile welt die existierte großmutter
schreibt zum beispiel wir gehen auf eine
insel in einer offenen kutsche
dort sehen wir andere glückliche
menschen wie wir es sind
und dann wird es düster die dinge ändern
sich den anekdoten die sie erzählt ist
eine wachsende unruhe zu spüren zum
beispiel das gefühl bei der heimfahrt in
der calle verfolgt zu werden
[Musik]
auch der vater fürchtet sich wenn er
nachts das hotel verlässt
[Musik]
im oktober zieht die familie ein erstes
mal um
dieser umzug leitet das ende ihrer
kindheit ein während die kindliche
unbeschwertheit vergeht steigt die
besorgnis
[Musik]
guten tag meine liebe angelika
willkommen zu hause
die reise war mühsam die weiße armee
steht vor den toren von pia tigers
hoffen wir dass da kriegen nicht bis sie
hervorbringt auch wenn sich die lage
beruhigen sollte die stimmung bleibt
gedrückt die bolschewiki haben alle
zeitungen geschlossen außer ihrem
eigenen blatt wir beklagten uns über die
zensur unter dem zahn und hast du von
der kollektivierung der landwirtschaft
gehört war ja kein hirngespinst völlig
utopisch ausgerechnet jetzt wo die
bauern land bekommen haben erzählt denen
mal was von kollektivierung die lachen
euch ins gesicht aber sie ist teil des
kommunistischen programms es stimmt mich
sie sind verrückt
total verrückt wenn sie den menschen die
kollektivierung aufzwingen wird das
genannt blutbad enden
das führt zur wirtschaftlichen
katastrophe
lehrer mein vater etwas aufgeschlossener
gewesen hätte mehr von früher erzählt
wäre es anders gekommen
ganz bestimmt
wir halten kurz an und kaufen
mineralwasser ist in ordnung
entschuldigen sie da wie sie etwas
fragen der welt dort vorne ist das bad
camberg ja das ist ja und wie kommen wir
da hin gehen sie diese straße entlang
und dort vorne führt ein weg hinauf
hinauf
ja aber seid vorsichtig da gibt es
schlangen
vielen dank auf wiedersehen
sie sagt es gebe schlangen dort wir
müssen vorsichtig sein
mamma mia da ist er der kamel berg kennt
mir kurz anhalten um den berg von weitem
zu sehen
jan sobald ich einen geeigneten platz
findet
[Musik]
auch hier
das ist ein uhr aus jetzt wo war
unglaublich muss
der grabstein noch steht das ist
unglaubliches glück grabsteine wie diese
die aus der zeit vor der revolution
stammen wurden größtenteils zerstört
deshalb finden so wie leute ihre
vorfahren nicht mehr sie haben großes
glück
sie sagt dass fast alle grabsteine
zerstört worden sind
[Musik]
fünfter november 1918 mit zittrigen
händen beschreibe ich die heutigen
ereignisse eine abteilung der roten
armee hat unsere kolonie geplündert und
zerstört
pure schreckliche gewalt eine
nachbarsfrau oder erdrosselt
mein freund eduardo plot liegt im
sterben frauen und kinder konnten wir
retten indem wir sie im stall versteckt
[Musik]
draußen ist alles ruhig
du solltest schlafengehen geht es denn
sie sind eingeschlafen aber sie haben
ich werde mich noch einmal beim
vorsitzenden des sowjets beschweren
wie viele plünderungen haben wir nun
schon erlitten mitglieder wie oft müssen
wir noch zu sehen wie fanatiker und
betrunkene aus blinder wut alles
zerstören was ihnen in die hände kommt
umbringen wenn sie wollen wir können
nicht länger hier bleiben mitglieder
wir können nicht warten bis es auch uns
trifft es reicht bitte
wir sollten vielleicht jemanden finden
wir fragen können guten tag
unsere gäste aus der schweiz suchen nach
informationen über ihre vorfahren die
hier vor vielen jahren gewohnt haben
von schweizern weiß ich nichts hier
lebten italiener aus der italienischen
schweiz aus der italienischen schweiz
das war ihr haus es war eine ganze
familie
roters hausstand dahinten es hieß
hausrat- die das haus partie stand da
hinten
jetzt steht dort ein anderes haus aber
die kellerräume sind geblieben
der keller gehört noch zum alten hausrat
anstelle des hauses therapie steht jetzt
ein anderes haus aber die kellerräume
sind noch dieselben
da wie sie etwas fragen warten sie ich
schalte dem motor aus vor der revolution
gab es hier eine schweizerisch
italienische kolonie wissen sie etwas
darüber
ja die haben hier geliebt sie hatten
wunderschöne rehberge aber fragen sie
alexandra dehne alexandra wenn ihr diese
straße entlanggeht werdet ihr sie finden
vielen dank
[Applaus]
hören sie
gehen sie um das dorf herum dahinter
lagen die leinberger
diese leute hatten wunderschöne
weinberge sie haben aus dem nichts
zahlreiche tätigkeiten aufgebaut
sie hatten verstanden dass weinreben in
diesem klima gut gedeihen
man lebte gut hier sie brachten den
leuten viel arbeit bis die bolschewiki
kam auf wiedersehen
guten tag
das sind unsere gäste aus der schweiz
guten tag wunderbar dass ihr das ist
herab das ist das erste das ist mein
großvater in frage kommt ins haus
ich bin eine alte dame und werde rasch
müde wenn ich lange stehen muss sie ist
etwas alt und bittet sie einzutreten
keine angst vor den hunden valerio
kannst du dir sagen dass ich fotos bei
mir habe
die hier unser werk dkb bank
und das ist das große haus
das wurde vollständig abgebrochen
das war ein lagerhaus und hier unten war
der keller
den gibt es noch
da das hier ist der wein kennen und hier
vorne führte ein weg durch
und das ist mein vater auf dem hof
herrschte immer ordnung
es war schön anzusehen überall blumen
schön gepflegte weinberge der kommt aus
italien
[Gelächter]
es freut mich sehr dass ich mich in
diesen sessel setzen darf den sessel
meiner grossmutter urgrossmutter wer
weiß
[Musik]
und hier ist noch eine reliquie
die weinkellerei matschie
ein weinfass praktisch in die wand
eingebaut wie in melide das ist einfach
einzigartig
wunderbar
[Musik]
nein
achter november 1918
gestern haben wir unsere geliebte
kolonie verlassen und all unser hab und
gut zurückgelassen
es war zu gefährlich geworden
wilde horden strom wenn weinkeller um
sich zu betrinken
wir wohnen bei einer familie in ein
nachbardorf an schlafen zu acht in einem
zimmer aneinander gefecht wie die
sardinen unser einziges ziel ist mit dem
leben davonzukommen
[Musik]
unser urgroßvater hatte dem direktor des
hotel de rome versprochen dass er seine
stelle nicht verlassen würde eine
vorstellung aus dem letzten jahrhundert
er versprach seinem patron treue bis zum
letzten augenblick
[Musik]
doch am ende stürmten die branche listen
auch das hotel tyrol
die bolschewiki besetzten das hotel de
rome verwüsteten die herrlichen zwieten
in denen einst persönlichkeiten aus der
ganzen welt logiert hatten
sie plünderten den weinkeller mit
erstklassigen weinen und nahmen alles
mit was ihnen in die finger kam direkt
von luther erst jetzt rief der
hoteldirektor meinen vater zu sich und
beiden war klar dass dies das ende war
der vater dem verwaltungsrat des hotels
versprochen hatte dass er das restaurant
bis zum ende führen würde
betrachtete er sich von seiner aufgabe
erlöst und reicht er seine kündigung ein
[Musik]
ich glaube es ist ihm überaus schwer
gefallen dieses land zu verlassen
es muss ihm das herz zerrissen haben
dieses land aufgeben zu müssen
[Musik]
wer mit etwa zehn jahren hat er unsere
großmutter eine blinddarmentzündung und
wurde operiert
der arzt verschriebene zweiwöchigen
genesung so lauber mehr
ein kunde des hotel europe empfahl den
eltern ein kleines hotel auf der krim
[Musik]
natürlich hat er meine großmutter den
fotoapparat dabei food und so entdeckte
ich zu meiner großen überraschung dass
die besitzer dieses hotels ließen meine
urgroßmutter und meine großmutter haben
also zwei wochen in diesem hotel gewohnt
es ist doch unglaublich dass sie so weit
weg von sankt petersburg auf der krim
ausgerechnet bei tessin an logierten
[Musik]
der zufall wollte also dass sich die
geschichte der kleinen german kaufmann
nach ihrer operation mit dem schicksal
der familie rajhi kreuzten in einem
kleinen hotel in europa turia am
schwarzen meer
niemand kannte das hotel das die rabbis
während mindestens einem sommer geführt
haben
vielleicht sollte einer der söhne ins
hotelgeschäft einsteigen aber die sind
reine vermutungen
es war im sommer 1916 zweieinhalb jahre
vor der flucht
[Applaus]
31 dezember 1918 der letzte tag eines
schrecklichen jahres wir sind einer
frieler bande ausgeliefert leuten die
keinen funken menschlichkeit in sich
tragen noch sozialistische oder
kommunistische ideale vertreten täglich
hören wie sie sagen man müsse alle
bursch war ausmerzen
so nennen sie uns boris war wo wir das
ganze leben hart gearbeitet haben
[Musik]
siebzehnter januar 1919 endlich frei
nach einer weiteren nacht voller
schrecken und gewalt hat die vorhut der
einheimischen kavalleristen und kadetten
die sowjet truppen zurückgeschlagen
die freude über die befreiung ist
unbeschreiblich
unsere bei freier sind kavalleristen aus
dem kaukasus kabine transkaukasien
datencheck gästen aus dem koran nomaden
soldaten die aspiranten bekannt sind
ausgerechnet sie erlösen uns von der
gehassten und grausamen tyrannei der
russischen sozialistischen anarchie
[Musik]
20 jahren war 1919 adieu mein kamel berg
wir haben beschlossen noch heute nacht
zu fahren sollten die sowjets dieser
region erneut besetzen wären wir völlig
verloren der kommandant der kadetten
truppe lässt uns nach noworossijsk am
schwarzen meer fahren wo wir vielleicht
ein schiff finden mit dem wir russland
verlassen können
[Musik]
23 jahren war 1919
seit zwei tagen sitzen wir in diesem
bahnhof fest die wahlzelle sind
überfüllt mit kriegsgefangenen
verletzten typhus kranken und toten
am nachmittag erhalten wir endlich die
bewilligung in einen zug zu steigen und
richtung norden zu fahren
[Musik]
inzwischen dämmert es wir sehen die
steppe des kubanern uns vorbeiziehen
brach und verlassen liegt sie da genau
so wie wir sie bei unserer ankunft vor
23 jahren vorgefunden haben
[Musik]
24 jahren war 1919
mit dem tageslicht kommt wieder etwas
hoffnung auf wir fahren dem gefrorenen
fluss kuban entlang
jedes mal wenn der zug hält erstarren
wir vor schreck
[Musik]
wir mussten die reise unterbrechen und
einer unterkunft suchen beide in berlin
sind krank die eine hat bronchitis die
andere eine lungenentzündung
wir wohnen in einem kleinen hotel beim
bahnhof es kommen laufend neue
flüchtlinge an
ganze karawanen von fliehenden menschen
einige haben hunderte von kilometern auf
die wagen zurückgelegt zehnter februar
1919 die mädchen haben sich erholt und
wir setzen unsere reise fort
beim anblick der berge waren wir ganz
aufgeregt dahinter liegt noworossijsk
und das schwarze meer
fünfzehnter februar 1919 wir können es
kaum glauben
wir können an bord gehen nach zwei tagen
laufen wir in odessa 1
dort warten wir auf die weiterfahrt
und am 11 märz sind wir in griechenland
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wir warten auf eine möglichkeit um nach
italien zu kommen
aber wenigstens sind wir außer gefahr
haben alles verloren
aber wir sind in sicherheit
[Musik]
frau
mit gallery wird nicht mehr erleben wie
sie seine prognosen und ängste
bewahrheiten
doch er sollte recht behalten nach
wenigen jahren kommt dass in der ganzen
sowjetunion zur zwangskollektivierung
zahlreiche bauern wehren sich dagegen
und werden entweder deportiert wurde
getötet
die lebensmittelproduktion geht
drastisch zurück was schließlich zur
schrecklichen hungersnot führt die sich
bis heute im kollektiven gedächtnis der
menschen im russischen kaukasus als
schlimmstes übel gehalten hat
[Musik]
sein tod kam unerwartet
daran ist er gestorben
19 die leute sagten vermutlich er sein
herz schmerz gestorben das hörte man oft
in den dörfern
er ist an herzschmerz gestorben was
bedeutet das
herzschmerz dass das herz weibrecht
und genau das geschieht ja eigentlich
bei einem herzinfarkt wenn die
herzmuskeln zerrissen werden daher bin
ich überzeugt dass er einen herzinfarkt
erlitten hat und da dieser so unerwartet
kam konnte die familie nicht gleich ein
grab für ihn finden wo sollte er
begraben werden
schließlich konnten sie den großvater in
das familiengrab der familie sardinien
einer capella familie
und auch wieder sehen wo großvater ruhe
in frieden
[Musik]